Dobby just awakened his secret ice fire
Quirk his true Quirk that was hidden all
this time and this changes everything we
thought we knew where this war was
heading we thought we knew how the
battles were going but horikoshi just
dropped an absolute bombshell so let's
get into it you guys know how this works
if you enjoy our mha vids and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now to help us
out with that YouTube algorithm and by
the way over half of the people who
watch my videos regularly are not
subscribed to the channel if you are one
of those people if you're feeling called
out right now please do me a big favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications it would
help me out a lot finally this video
will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter focused
primarily on the return of all might and
the impending showdown between him and
Primal for one on but that chapter also
reminded us of endeavor's fight with
Dobby a fight that is about to reach its
boiling point we learned that Dobby has
been compressing thermal energy inside
his body and it has reached such a high
temperature that it could literally
explode at any moment at this rate Dobby
will only be able to hold it together
for like another 10 minutes and then all
of that thermal energy that he
compressed will be released suddenly
that means his body will explode and the
explosion it creates will destroy
everything within a five kilometer
radius and if that alone wasn't bad
enough we learned that many of the
civilians who were hiding within the UA
shelter including the Todoroki family
are within range of the impending
explosion if Dobby really does explode
although civilians will be killed
including his own mother his brother
Natsu and his sister fuyumi almight then
contacted Shoto Nida and told them to
make their way from kamino to gunga
right away due to the unique nature of
their quirks they are the only ones who
can stop Dobby and save everyone from
the explosion Eda picks up Shoto on his
back and takes off at full speed
literally jumping from one building to
another as he pushes his Quirk to the
limit in order to get them to goonga as
soon as possible the latest chapter
starts off a bit unexpectedly we see two
villains from the Paranormal Liberation
Front getten and Mr compress talking to
each other in prison getten is
explaining the history of the himura
family and if that name sounds familiar
it is because that was shoto's mom's
maiden name before she married his
father Angie her maiden name was REI
himura getten says that back in the old
days there was a himura village Chief
who established multiple branches of the
himura family as soon as I heard this I
thought of like view chihas for some
reason but anyway let's move on this was
clearly a wealthy land-owning family
because gettin mentions that a land
reform that affected a lot of wealthy
Japanese landowners back in 1947 did not
affect the himura family's wealth and
pride at all meaning they were so big
that they were too big to fail this was
a very prestigious and influential
family and they took great pride in the
fact that their bloodline was pure and
undiluted the different branches of the
family essentially intermarried with
each other in order to keep the
bloodline pure which is definitely
something that a lot of royal families
did in our own world too but it's also a
terrible idea if you don't want your
children to be inbred and unhealthy with
the appearance of meta abilities or
quirks the himura family began to
decline and eventually they faced a
complete downfall the himura clan was
just too closed off from the outside
world and they failed to change with the
times as a result it seems that the
family became desperate for money and
the main branch started selling off its
members in Quirk marriages that would
give some benefit to the family as a
whole as we know shoto's mother Rey was
one of the people who were pressured
into a quirk marriage for the sake of
the family she was married off to Angie
Todoroki even though she barely knew him
because Angie thought that her powerful
ice Quirk would be a great genetic match
for his powerful fire Quirk and Rey's
family thought that this match would be
advantageous for them getten says that
after the main branch of the family
began basically selling off its members
to Quirk marriages the other branches of
the family scattered get it himself is a
member of one of these branches and he
was eventually recruited by redastro and
now that I think about it get and being
part of the same extended family as Rey
makes a lot of sense his white hair his
silver eyes and his powerful ice-based
Quirk are all very similar to Reyes and
although this random jailhouse convo
about the history of the himura family
might seem out of place in this chapter
there is a deeper meaning behind it
getten goes on to say that over the
generations meta abilities grow in
strength and complexity they intensify
as different factors mix together and it
wouldn't be surprising if someone had
latent abilities that they weren't even
aware of as gettin says these words the
chapter shows us Dobby and then after
the conversation between the two
villains runs its course the very next
scene is the fiery duel between Endeavor
and Dobby the meaning behind this
conversation is clear Dobby may have a
latent Quirk power inside of him a quirk
that stems from the other side of his
family the himura side we know that
Dobby inherited his father's flame-based
Quirk but he did not inherit his
father's resistance to fire instead he
inherited his mother's resistance to ice
even though he himself could not produce
do size but what if Dobby has a latent
ice based ability as gettin's speech
seems to be implying what if Dobby also
has the ability to use both Fire and Ice
just like Shoto but his ice powers just
haven't manifested yet if Dobby were to
suddenly unlock a new secret Quirk what
would that mean for his battle against
Endeavor and what would that mean for
the Final War as a whole hold on to that
thought and let's get back to the
chapter we see Endeavors struggling to
resist the massive fiery Inferno that
Dobby's body is currently producing
Dobby looks like the personification of
a supernova he doesn't even look human
anymore he looks like a wild fiery
monster like a mad flaming nomu Endeavor
has now been informed that Dobby is
about to explode and that the explosion
could kill both the civilians inside the
UA shelter and the heroes who are still
fighting against toga and the twice
clones unfortunately Endeavor has
already taken a lot of damage in his
fight against all for one and he doesn't
think that he'll be able to lure Dobby
much further away from their current
location for his part Dobby looks
absolutely terrifying he's like a human
furnace fire is erupting from every part
of his body and he is rushing an
Endeavor while screaming Dad look at me
he almost sounds like a child asking his
father to see what he can do and that is
exactly how Endeavor sees it even though
Dobby now looks like a flaming monster
and never can't help but remember little
Toya as a child and this is of course
preventing Endeavor from giving it his
all in this fight Endeavor doesn't want
to hurt his son Toya and never feels
personally responsible for everything
that happened to Toya and so Endeavor
keeps getting hit and taking damage from
Dobby because he can't bring himself to
kill his own son Endeavor screams at
Dobby to put out his his Flames because
he doesn't want his son to die but Dobby
seems to have completely lost his mind
he's reverted back to his childhood and
even calls out to Natsu and asks him to
play with him and to be clear Endeavor
is in serious trouble the heat that
Dobby is generating is hot enough to
burn even him despite the fact that he
has a natural resistance to extreme heat
and Endeavor can literally feel himself
losing Consciousness as a result of the
insanely high temperature that Dobby is
producing Endeavor doesn't know how
Dobby is even still alive unlike
Endeavor he doesn't have a natural
resistance to heat and Flames he should
not be able to survive this and yet he
is alive and he's still fighting as
Dobby gets close to Endeavor and jumps
on top of him and never notices that
Dobby seems to be using phosphor he then
thinks of bakugou and the fact that when
someone has a near death experience this
experience could cause their Quirk to
awaken the high risk high pressure
situation could awaken the latent
abilities of a person especially when
they're on the verge of death and
honestly the fact that Dobby was able to
replicate shoto's phosphor back in
communal should have been our first clue
that something was going on here the
whole point of phosphor is that it
merges the two sides of shoto's Quirk
the fire and the ice into one so the
fact that Dobby could replicate phosphor
suggest that he always had a latent ice
side too otherwise him using phosphor in
any way just wouldn't make sense and
right there in that moment Dobby awakens
Rey's Quirk or at least that is what
Endeavor calls it it's clearly some sort
of ice Quirk but we have to remember
that this Quirk could be unique to Dobby
and different from Reyes Endeavor thinks
back to his family and everything they
went through because of him he then
acknowledges yet again that this is all
his responsibility and he decides that
he can't let Dobby or rather Toya die
alone but he won't let him drag anyone
else into this either Endeavor decides
to use a combination of his own
Firepower and the Firepower that Dobby
is currently generating to propel both
of them as far into the sky as possible
as he holds Dobby in his arms and takes
off Endeavor is planning to take them
both into the sky together before Dobby
explodes then when he does explode he
will kill both himself and Endeavor but
they will hopefully be high enough for
everyone else on the ground to survive
Endeavor makes the conscious decision to
sacrifice his own life in order to atone
for his sins and in order to take
responsibility for his past mistakes but
before Endeavor can carry out his plan
his wife and Dobby's mother Rey appears
she seems to be using her ice Quirk
powers to try and cool Dobby off so he
doesn't explode and the very final panel
of the chapter shows Rey remembering a
young Toya telling her you're guilty too
Mom and that is how this chapter ends
whoa this was such a great chapter for
the past few chapters I kind of stopped
even thinking about the Dobby fight with
all the focus on Prime all for one and
his impending Showdown with all might
but horikoshi's just succeeded in making
me extremely interested in this fight as
well we see that Rey is now also taking
responsibility for what happened to Toya
both parents are sharing part of the
blame for how it all went down and now
they are both risking their lives to try
to save their son but can Rey and
Endeavor do something together to
actually save Dobby or is it just too
late to save him does Rey getting
involved mean that both of the Todoroki
parents are about to sacrifice their
lives will they die will they survive
will one of them die and the other
survive I want to see your predictions
down in the comments below right now
finally we have to of course talk about
Dobby Awakening his secret Quirk his ice
fire Quirk the true power that has been
dormant inside of him this entire time
the clues were there of course his hair
turning white the fact that he didn't
die after being terribly burnt during
this war even though he doesn't have
resistance to flames and heat and of
course his use of phosphor and I know
that quite a few people called this way
back years ago but it's just so
interesting to see it all play out and
by the way this chapter in particular
has clearly confirmed that Dobby does
have some form of resistance to heat and
Flames even Endeavor is shocked that
Dobby can handle so much heat without
dying and in fact the heat that Dobby is
producing is actually too much for
endeavor to handle Endeavor is being
burned Endeavor is on the verge of
losing consciousness because of the Heat
and yadavi who should have died long ago
under these conditions is still alive
and still fighting the truth is that
Dobby does have resistance to heat and
Flames just not on the surface his skin
is not resistant so his skin can get
burned and injured but the rest of his
body beneath the surface clearly does
have superhuman heat and Fire Resistance
if it didn't he would have been dead
long ago we already knew that Dobby's
flame Quirk is even stronger than his
father's so it's possible that his ice
work is also even stronger than his
mother's or perhaps I should say the ice
side of his Quirk because it's likely
that just like Shoto Toya has one Quirk
with two very distinct signs it's almost
like two different quirks but they're
very interconnected ironically Toya was
the Sun that endeavor had been hoping
for All Along The One who could use both
Fire and Ice but the fact that he didn't
have flame resistance on the surface of
his body on his skin and the fact that
the ice side was dormant inside of him
LED endeavored to start discouraging
Toya from becoming a hero and he ended
up placing all of his focus on Shoto
instead but by doing this even though he
just wanted to spare his son from
injuring himself Endeavor created a
villain he created a son who really is
just as powerful as he had always hoped
but who in the process of attaining that
power became a true monster what do you
guys think how will Dobby's Fireside and
newly awakened ice side come together
will they be two distinct forces or will
they create something new like ice fire
something that burns and freezes at the
same time something that could be super
effective against both endeavor's Quirk
and race Quirk will Dobby use his eyes
side to cool his temperature and prevent
himself from exploding like do you think
he will actually survive this war or
will he still end up overheating and
killing himself in the process on top of
that is he going to kill his parents
along the way or will one or both of
them survive the fight don't forget to
give me your thoughts on this crazy
reveal and what's going to happen next
down in the comments below if you're
looking for an mha video to watch next
don't ignore my video on all 20 class 1a
quirks in that video I explain all the
quirks including their upgrades and
updates as of the final Arc of the story
so check it out Link in the description
and on screen if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more mha content in
the future leave a quick like right now
and if you're one of the over 50 of
people who watch my videos but haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all note notifications